what is up everybody so i just wanted to
do a quick video
on a key program for a 2011 to 2017
honda odyssey
with the altel im 608 as you can tell
uh new key and then old key which is
very broken um so just wanted to walk
through this
and show you guys how the
all tell does with honda
so we're just gonna go through
diagnostics then we're gonna pick our
car
and we're gonna go through and pick our
system
usa
so i used to use the varus edge on my
key programs and it did
most of um
most of the system or most of the cars
i'm sorry but um
unfortunately not too long ago i had
a couple acuras that i couldn't do and i
had already told the customers that i
could do them
and so i called snap-on tech
and come to find out it was they were
still supposed to do it
but there was something wrong with the
software so they had to do an update and
it wouldn't be fixed into the following
update
so then of course i had to take those
vehicles to um
i had to take before i get going too too
close in here let's see
oops sorry i'm talking and then just
just walking through this here
um so anyway so yeah so i had to take
him to the dealer spend a couple hours
there pay the dealer to program them
it was a pain so that's why i got the
im608 because i didn't want to have to
deal with that
as well as i wanted to be able to do
multiple other keys as well
um so as you saw i went through
diagnostic diagnostics then i went
through system selection
and i chose immobilizer and then it
automatically detects
and then you go into a mobilizer setup
and it'll load up here it's pretty easy
and it
the great thing about the im608 is it
walks you through everything
um and honda's are super easy anyways so
we're gonna go add delete keys
and then
okay
let it load and we're gonna add one key
normally you need to read all that stuff
especially if you're doing something
you've never done so
turn the key off turn it back
on we're gonna turn it off i'm sure and
then pull the key out put the new key in
that's typically how this works
but i could be wrong because this is
actually the first time i've used the
im608
on a honda so
turn it off within 16 seconds okay on
the new key
put our new key in on
oh
on without changing the key
off again i think on one last time i
believe
so it's real similar to the way
the varus edge did it and then actually
pretty similar to the way
the uh honda hds did as well when i was
at the dealership
um so is it mobilizer turned off
immobilizer light is
turned off so we go yes
turn it off key has been programmed
car starts cool
so we will do that okay off
and one last time
okay we already ensured that it started
the car
and this is the kia
switchblade key no
okay so let's see sometimes
on these newer ones it actually programs
the lock and unlock
yep so it actually
the hook the hood's open so it won't
honk the horn but
you can see program that as well
plus obviously like i said it um
starts the car as well so that's it it's
that quick so this video is five minutes
long and you guys saw i uh
was messing around too so it's super
quick so if you don't uh have this
in as an option for yourself as
programming keys or as an option in your
shop
i highly recommend it um obviously this
is super easy they're not all this easy
uh and it can be kind of nerve-wracking
sometimes
but i definitely highly recommend adding
the im608 to your arsenal of
scan tools it's highly worth it i've
done lexus keys
as well already and toyota keys which
are easy as
well and i'm looking forward to jumping
in and doing some more
like ford keys and chevy keys and um i
know that this will actually skip the
uh like i think i forget i think it's
the 10 minute uh
wait time on the gm's so
uh that whole process i think it's 30
minutes in total but you have to
constantly go back out turn the key off
and turn it on every like 10 minutes or
something like that it's been a while
since i've done one but it'll actually
bypass that
so anyways hopefully you guys liked the
video if you like the content feel free
to check out some of my other videos um
kind of just miscellaneous automotive
stuff so if you're interested in that
stuff feel free to
subscribe like it if you like it if you
have any questions about the im608 feel
free to reach out i know there's not a
ton a ton of information
um i can try to give you as much as i
can on my end
um so far there is a function viewer on
it as well which will tell you like
certain vehicles that it'll do
which is really cool so it'll go through
i wonder if i can do that real quick no
i'll have to
exit out let's see well maybe i can
function viewer
as you can see i'm recording on my phone
all right so you can see i've done it in
here a few times
so like uh lincoln so i
you go in and you type in which vehicle
you want and then it tells you like
each one of these what they record what
they um
represent so these symbols over here
and then it tells you what it'll do
which is really cool
so i thought that was awesome so that
way you can check
before and if a customer calls you is
like hey i have like this customer
called me oops not a passport called me
on the linkedin and said hey i need a
key
i looked it up yes i can add keys no
problem so
that was really cool so awesome thanks
guys appreciate you watching the video
have a great day thanks see you bye